let's go next to the four four three
area code who's calling from four four
three hey David this is Michael how's it
going hey good Mike go ahead
alright I'm from Maryland then a have a
question that kind of spans the 2016
election they've also be relevant and
before we get to that question Mike
we're not like on speakerphone right
no I thought all right yeah okay you're
maybe that's a little better maybe you
were a little far from the phone yeah
yeah I wasn't actually really I think
sorry okay go ahead Mike right so this
is kind of spurred from a talk I saw
Chris Hedges give where he was saying
that he thinks Bernie Sanders initially
failed at the start by running under the
Democratic Party I was wondering if you
agree with that and if you think that
Bernie's and I even thinking that his
help for the Democratic Party will pay
off for him in the future okay so to
basically two-part question right number
one is was it a mistake for Bernie
Sanders to run as a Democrat from the
get-go Bernie Sanders would not be as
well-known as he is today had he run as
an independent from the beginning that's
just a reality yes he might have made it
onto the November ballot
rather than having lost the primary to
Hillary Clinton and then not being on
the ballot in November but the power
that he has had to influence the
Democratic Party is because he ran as a
Democrat now you might look at the
Democratic Party and say David what the
hell are you talking about the
Democratic Party hasn't changed in any
way I agree that the Democrat Democratic
Party hasn't changed enough as a result
of what happened in 2016 or since 2016
but some of the changes we have seen
including positions on health care and a
number of Democrats who now are getting
behind Medicare for all at least in
principle minimum wage I think Bernie
has been responsible for that is it
enough of a change we can debate that
right so so I I think that you can say
it was a mistake for Bernie to run as a
Democrat because he's not really in line
with the views of the Democratic Party
right like it's an ideological mistake
but pragmatically I think that he's done
a lot of good by running as a Democrat I
say I agree with that assessment this is
a quick little follow-up yeah do you
think that when the
by 20 election rolls around still sort
of be swept under the carpet in the
mainstream press like he was in 2016
we're only afterwards did he start
receiving adequate attention
I think it'll happen if he runs in 2020
to a lesser degree than it did in 2016
but there that probably still will
happen if there's kind of like big-name
sort of corporate Democrats or media
friendly Democrats or whatever you want
to call them okay thank you for your
answer I appreciate the time all right
yeah thank you for the call appreciate
it Mike